foreign
let's do this then so I know people will
keep walking in that's totally fine
um well done to those of you who have
made it here at the appointed moment uh
on this day after the party last night
um it's impressive to see you here and
I'm very glad to do so
um so my name is Steve I know some of
you not all of you I work at Microsoft I
work on the.net team and I particularly
work on stuff to do with the web so
that's aspina Blazer other front-end web
stuff and I've worked with the web I
think for my whole professional career
which is quite a while and I really like
it I think it's a great area of
technology to specialize in it's clearly
very very important you know there's
pretty much every developer in the world
has to do some stuff with web technology
from time to time so it's nice to be in
that but it does keep changing right
like let's be clear we're constantly
inventing new ways of doing stuff over
and over again and probably you would
agree that on average over 2 time things
get more complex rather than less
complex and I sometimes wonder well why
is that how did we get to this who
decided to make up all these things and
why did they do it and like could they
have done it differently was it all a
big mistake
so that's kind of what this talk is
designed to look into we're going to go
back through some of the major events
through Webb's history and see what
happened and who the characters were
what they decided to do and what they
were offering
now obviously this is just one person's
subjective telling of the story it's not
an absolute truth it's a mixture of some
research and some first-hand experiences
from certain parts of it that I was
there for but I can't cover everything
and inevitably I will miss out whichever
is your personal favorite thing so just
let's just accept that limitation the
goal will be that at the end of this
when you go back into your web
development jobs you will be able to see
so many things that are there and think
oh yeah I see that came from that
technology and oh that reminds me of how
this person was trying to solve a
problem in a certain way and maybe
that'll put into perspective a little
bit of where the web is and where it
even might go in the future we'll talk a
little bit about that right at the end
so if we're going to talk about where
the web came from we should obviously
start right at the beginning and the
obvious place to do that is with someone
that I'm sure you've heard of Tim
berners-lee who was working at CERN in
Switzerland at the end of the 80s early
90s and you know even that he invented
the web right but do you know why do you
know what he was trying trying to
achieve at the time well apparently CERN
was quite a complicated place to work
you know they had a lot of big projects
going they were building particle
accelerators and such like and
berners-lee kept track of all his work
in a piece of software that he wrote
called inquire and it was kind of like a
notes management thing that he made and
he had a kind of primitive hypertext
thing going on because he was able to
link from one note to another note and
he really liked this system and he
thought everybody should use it he
really wanted everyone in CERN to
standardize on this and in fact he even
wanted to go further and network
everyone's notebooks together so you can
see where this is going right so he
wrote this proposal and he submitted it
Information Management a proposal and
there's loads of stuff in there that you
would not recognize today because it's
all specific to know to um sir and it's
quite hard to make sense of but there's
some parts in there that you would
recognize for example this picture here
a picture in which he depicts the idea
of a client browser which runs on many
platforms and connects to a hypertext
server you would probably also recognize
this this is the idea of a server which
takes existing database content and
makes it look like hypertext in other
words he was inventing server-side
rendering there right in his very first
document and the reason why he was
concerned with database content was he
knew that there was a good chance that
if he submits this proposal everyone
will go oh that's a good proposal and
then just completely ignore it like how
many of you have done that in your work
like yeah it's a common thing he knew
that would happen so his hack to make
people use this was to take some
information that they actually needed
specifically the CERN phone book and
automatically generate the hypertext for
that from a database now he didn't just
write these documents he also prototyped
some implementations of a web server and
a web browser and we've got the source
code for those two things right here
today so I'm going to show you the very
first web server that there ever was and
it's this file called TCP server.c and
it's what is it it's 700 something lines
of C code and the code quality is
well it's clearly a prototype and I
think we've all done some pretty bad
things in our prototypes but the great
thing about this is that it actually
worked and in fact we can still compile
and run it today I had to make about
three very small tweaks to the code to
deal with some compiler errors and then
it built in a modern GCC so to do that
let's run GCC to compile that to that
web server there and we've just built a
22 kilobyte binary HTTP Daemon and that
is the original web server so let's run
it
okay and that's running now and you can
see that it's listening on Port 2784
that's a bit weird right why is it that
why isn't it poor 80. well we'll come to
that in a second
um now I can't connect a modern web
browser to this because this only speaks
a very ancient dialect of httpd which
has been lost in time and now the only
way we can really talk to it is to
connect to it from telnet so I'm going
to do that so let's go telnet and
connect to that now if you know anything
about HTTP you would think that probably
the way to get it to do something would
be to do something like this to get the
home page that's how a modern browser
would would do something but if we try
that it just goes unrecognized command
get and that's a bit strange because if
you read the source code you see that it
does have stuff to do with get requests
but if you reverse engineer it a little
bit more what you'll find is that if you
say get and then the name of a file
that's actually in that directory then
it will serve that file to you so the
very first web server was a static files
web server which is the sort I think we
still do today so that makes sense now
it's not just that it's also got a bunch
of other things that we wouldn't
recognize now like it's got this find
feature that's built in to the web
server and it also is a place where Tim
establishes a beautiful tradition for
web servers which continues to this day
which is having terrible security
vulnerabilities and we can see one quite
easily right here the one that really
stands out most I think is on line 286
here this system call here that's going
to execute some code by like calling out
to the Shell to run a native program and
what is this system command well it's
whatever we get when we concatenate a
bunch of user input together so that you
can just run arbitrary stuff on the
server which is you know very friendly
and community-minded
um you also might wonder about this
weird port number that they were using
well that port number changed a little
bit later if we look at the version
three of this technology you'll see this
is where they switched from the old port
to the Newport this Old Port number
apparently those are the last four
digits of berners-lee's parents phone
number supposedly
but then in 1992 they were allocated for
80. and that's when they said that they
felt that they'd really made it when
they got this nice round part number
so that's the original web server but
there's also an original web browser we
can have a look at that as well and
that's actually quite a much more
sophisticated piece of code and I'm
going to show you that inside next step
now how many of you are ever used Next
Step
zero okay so this was an operating
system created by a company called Next
which uh was run by Steve Jobs after he
was forced out of apple before he went
back to Apple and you can recognize a
lot of stuff in this in modern Mac OS
for example it has the spinning beach
ball whenever it's busy it also has this
kind of three column file browser which
you might recognize today and inside
this here I've got the source code for
World Wide web.app which burnsley wrote
and that can still be compiled and run
so let's have a go at running that
browser I've got it installed here if I
double click on this and what you'll see
is it's quite different from anything
that you would recognize as a modern
browser today so one thing is that every
page you open comes up in a separate
window which is just kind of like
floating around independently and then
the controls are all in this other
flirting window and we've got this back
and next and previous and stuff and you
probably think you know what that means
but I'm afraid you're wrong because back
sorry next and previous do not mean what
they mean in a modern web browser it's
something to do with like going through
a list of links incrementally it's kind
of hard to make sense of we've got other
stuff in here for example we've got the
uh this about screen that uh that burns
Lee put in let's see what that says it
says it's an exercise in global of
information availability so I'd say it's
pretty successful as an exercise as
things go we've also got uh what else
have we got in there we've got some
weird stuff that you wouldn't expect
check spelling so you can do spell
checking of the page that you're
visiting now you might think why on
Earth would you want to do that well
there's a good reason okay because this
is not just a web browser any page you
go to you can just start changing it
right you can just edit anything that
you see and it's even got this
surprisingly sophisticated style editor
where I can go and choose different
styles or they're kind of hard to see
we've got all this like configuration
stuff that shows up and we've even got
various Diagnostics where we can do
showing the HTML sources and seeing
other things about what's going on so
we've kind of got early browser Dev
Tools in there right at the very
beginning
now in terms of the ability to edit size
well it makes sense right because
berners-lee's idea was that this was a
big globally shared networked notebook
which people should be able to edit so
you know kind of like early Echoes of
um Wikipedia in there but of course it
was always designed to be distributed
not just a single server so that's the
original web browser
um it did have a bit of a critical flaw
as a plan though so let's just get out
of there and we'll talk about that so
the big problem here was that bernersley
has made this lovely web browser
prototype which runs on next but no one
apart from Tim has a next computer in
CERN so this project is at serious risk
of just dying like in its first week but
thankfully it was rescued now there was
an intern at CERN at that time called
Nicola pello and she could see what
burns Lee was doing and what the
potential was in that and she could also
see that it was immediately just going
to fail because no one else can run this
browser and thankfully she invented a
way of rendering the hypertext as plain
text that would be possible to use on
the computers that other people had
actually got so I think we can be very
glad for that because we would not be
here talking about the web if that
hadn't happened but that's just text
mode and that's not really what people
wanted people wanted a graphical browser
that was kind of obvious as soon as this
was made public people started creating
their own browsers and the first one
that was perhaps recognizable to
modernize is this one viola you can see
it's got the address bar at the top it's
got back and forward and it more or less
does what you think it's going to do and
it looks nice but it's also really
Innovative in other ways Pei Wei who
created this also added style sheets now
it's not CSS obviously that hadn't been
invented yet but it was a thing like
that that he came up with and put in
there and you can kind of see how that
would work from the syntax but even more
impressively than that it had built-in
scripting again not JavaScript that
hadn't been invented but the whole
browser was built in this kind of
scripting language and he allowed you to
embed the same scripting language in
your pages to dynamically change the
content so that really set some
direction for what a web page could do
now people didn't really use this at
scale either because this was a Unix
only thing the first browser that was
cross platform enough and friendly
enough for lots of people to use is this
thing NCSA Mosaic and I'm just going to
show you that before we get on to talk
and learn a little bit about how
programming worked for the web so I'm
going to show you that inside Windows
3.1 so let's bring that up now now might
be a bit before the time of most of you
I don't know why that's just gone black
what's going on here my screen has just
gone black mysteriously
don't know why
yeah that's because I'm doing a live
demo obviously that's uh that's the
primary reason okay well here it is
nope it does not like that all right
well I think we might do without seeing
Mosaic then because I don't know what's
going on with that
as soon as I can get back
yeah let's just kill that so Mosaic was
an early browser that looks familiar to
Modern people and
let's get back to there we go the main
Innovation that happened when Mosaic was
that it looked a lot like what you would
see today so it had all the kind of HTML
rendering that you would expect like
things are in paragraphs they've got
lists they've got links you can hover a
link and your cursor goes blue all of
that kind of traditional stuff but the
main thing that was the really big
surprising Innovation was inline images
now up until that point browsers did not
render images inside Pages you had to
open them in a separate window
so you might be thinking well how did
this new standard come to be what did
the standardization process look like at
that time was there a standardization
process so let's get a little snapshot
of what that was like for the people at
the time
so there was no standards bodies at this
time there was just a mailing list and
one day the person who was building this
um
this web browser Mark Andreessen who
we're going to hear more about in a
minute he sent a message to this mailing
list saying hey I'd like to present a
new HTML tag called IMG and I wanted to
have an attribute called Circ okay and
then he gives an example of that at the
bottom
and a reply comes back almost straight
away saying oh yeah I've already
invented that exact thing except my
invention is totally different
um and why don't you call it image and
why isn't the attribute Source oh that's
a very reasonable question I think we
can all agree that's a good question
um however nobody addressed that point
whatsoever it was totally ignored
because berners-lee then came in and he
said no no no no hang on a minute it
should not be called ing or even image
it should be an a tag and it should be
Rel equals embed comma present because
clearly that's much more intuitive and
developers are going to like that a lot
better
so then they had a little bit of a
heated debate for a few days where they
were pitching their counter proposals
and berners-lee was really sticking to
the idea that no it really really would
be more appropriate for it to be an a
tag but then he makes a bit of a
tactical error because he says oh we we
can't change HTML now anyway because
it's being standardized we just have to
leave it as it is
now unfortunately having made that
blunder that gave the opportunity for
Andresen to come back and say well Tim I
absolutely agree with you in all cases
which is why I'm gonna completely ignore
you and do what I said originally even
if your standards say otherwise browsers
have just got to innovate so he went
ahead and did that and he came back a
couple of weeks later to confirm yeah
we're definitely going with IMG and
Cirque like I said in the first place I
wasn't really asking your permission
this is just what I'm gonna do so I
don't know if berners-lee felt at all
burned by this exchange but it just so
happens that the following year he set
up the w3c a body who's uh whose role is
to have a sort of moral Authority about
what browser makers should do and give
them a nice shiny badge that they can
put on their product if they are
compliant
and at this time the web was growing
rapidly there were probably hundreds if
not thousands of web pages by now and it
was growing so fast it was literally
going up by a factor of 10 every year it
did that every year between about 92 and
97 and a whole order of magnitude growth
it was incredibly fast and one of the
high points of this comes in 94.95 when
two big corporations show up well
Netscape was not a big Corporation
originally they were a startup so
Andresen who had worked on Mosaic he
left and he went to work for a startup
and they weren't going to make a web
browser they actually wanted to make an
online gaming Network for the Nintendo
64. but Nintendo were just taking too
long to release that console and so they
said well what should we do instead oh I
don't know should we just make another
browser maybe so they did that and
that's how Netscape Navigator was born
they went on to IPO the next year for an
incredible amount of money which started
the whole.com Boom and then another
company you might have heard of decided
to get into the game Microsoft so
Microsoft licensed the NCSA Mosaic code
they took that code they wrapped it in
some nice windowsey stuff and they
shipped that as Internet Explorer one
and this started the first browser was
between Netscape and Internet Explorer
which as you might know Internet
Explorer went on to win very
conclusively getting up to 96 market
share by 2001 which also caused a few
legal troubles for the company but it
was you know a resounding win for the
for the browser
anyway that's enough about browsers
let's talk a little bit about how web
programming actually worked and we'll
look at some of the Frameworks that
people would use around that time
so
up until now people who wanted to create
web pages they would either just write
HTML by hand or they would if they
wanted to do it dynamically they would
use something like Perl scripts or other
executables which would they would
connect to their browser to their server
through something called CGI
but someone called Rasmus Leo lured off
came along with the idea of wouldn't it
be nice if there was a dedicated
scripting system that was designed for
creating web pages and so in 95 he
released the personal homepage tools 1.0
and this is the original syntax okay so
this is an early sample you can see it
was done with HTML comments for
generating HTML it had some cool
powerful features like can you see it
does SQL queries there online six or
seven or something like that and of
course it has a SQL injection
vulnerability they always do it just
wouldn't be fun if they didn't that was
how it was meant to be in 95
and and I don't think to be honest that
Rasmus was entirely confident in um in
his what he was doing like when he was
asked about it later he was just like
what is this thing
um but we need to give credit to the
fact that this was one of the most
successful web Technologies there's ever
been you know much of the early web was
built with this and famously Facebook
was originally built with PHP and they
still use it at scale so you know very
successful actually
but now let's think a little bit about
front-end development 96 with the year
that we could say that front end was
born because it's where JavaScript
appeared it's when CSS and also two of
the big consumer-facing web page
creation tools now there had been many
HTML editors created over the last
couple of years
um things like hot metal and stuff like
that but Microsoft licensed this product
called front page they rebranded it and
they shipped it as a Microsoft thing and
this kind of took over the market
because it was so powerful it was like
ridiculously excessively powerful so
let's have a quick look about how that
looked at the time shall we so I'm gonna
go and go into uh what are we in here
Windows 95 so imagine it's a 1996 or so
and you want to create yourself a new
corporate website because you've heard
that dot-coms are all the rage so you
would have installed front page and then
you go in there and you start that up
and let's see what it takes to create
ourselves a website so when that shows
up we're going to create a page from a
wizard all right and what we're going to
do well I'm going to create a corporate
presence because you know my goal is to
get rich from.com stuff and I'm going to
call it I don't know Ultra Corp sounds
like a good name and then it's going to
ask me a few questions about the site
that I want to create oh apparently I've
already done that so let's call it
um Ultra Corp two because you know
that's probably even better still all
right so it's going to ask me some
questions now about the site that I want
to create so it's going to start with
um let's see what pages do you want to
have in there what do you want to have
on your pages and and then it just goes
on and on and on asking so many
questions about your website and then
finally it's going to go and actually
create it for us
all right so when that comes up and one
of the interesting things about this
that we'll see is that Microsoft knew
that people didn't really know how to
create a website at this time so one of
the things that front page does is it
kind of teaches you it's got this whole
to-do list system where it tells you all
the different tasks that you have to do
it's gone it's nice like graphical
overview of your site with all the links
in it and then you can double click on a
page to open up the actual editor
when I do that that pops up and
then we can start actually working on
our site now in terms of the graphic
design it's it's kind of astonishing
really that this is the corporate
website template I do not know what the
designers were thinking but of course we
can go in and we can start editing stuff
you know uh let's just say my site I
don't know
um but as well as just creating the HTML
it also had some disturbingly powerful
features for example we can go to insert
script and if we choose to add some VB
script we can also make it run on the
server which is a very worrying thing
indeed so this was an early way that
people could use vbscript which is the
same thing that would automate office to
automate their web servers and people
did and they ran into some trouble with
that sort of thing we'll talk about a
little bit how that was resolved shortly
so let's just get back out of here nope
I do not wish to save that that can all
shut down all right
a bit of nostalgia there right so
JavaScript and CSS they were also coming
out at this same time maybe you've heard
the story about JavaScript about how it
was created in 10 days well it's true
apparently so Brendan Ike was hired to
work at Netscape and when he started
this said to him hey Brendan
um in 10 days we're going to have an all
hands meeting do you think it might be
possible for you to whip up some kind of
demo of like a scripting language that
could go inside the Netscape browser it
doesn't have to be any good like no
one's going to use it or anything and so
he he did it you know he worked hard he
spent 10 days and he created this
scripting thing that would go inside the
page
and some of the design guidance that he
was given by Andreessen at the start has
really shaped the course of JavaScript
all the way up to almost the present day
for example Andreessen said this can't
be a compiled language because I want
people to be able to just type the code
straight into their HTML pages and that
you know is a design decision that's
gone with us all the way up until uh
webassembly was eventually created
and then there's CSS so you know that
CSS was not really A New Concept Viola
had a concept of style sheets and many
people have proposed different sort of
style sheet designs over the years this
was a real Community effort there was a
bit of a design competition going on and
it was won by a proposal by hawk on
William Lee and it doesn't really look
much like modern CSS it doesn't have
curly braces it does have some features
that we don't have today but then
hawkcon continued working with a group
of a community group and they eventually
shaped that into what we have as CSS
today although browsers were very slow
to adopt it in any kind of sensible
manner
all right then so
what about accessibility that has to
come in somewhere along the line it's
obviously very important to us as web
developers today something we have to
know and think about
but it's kind of surprising how early it
was that accessibility became a thing
for the web and it's a good job that it
did
so here in Australia you've got the
disability Discrimination Act of 92 and
it does not talk about the web because
obviously the web was too new uh for it
to talk about that but it doesn't
exclude the web either and this act says
by default everything has to have
reasonable adaptations for disability
and so that automatically applied to the
web at the very moment it was first
invented and other countries had similar
rules so berners-lee knew that they were
going to have to do something about this
he sent out a message to a newsletter in
96 saying hey what are the best
practices what are people doing how are
we going to make this work well and then
the following year this led to having a
big meeting at the U.S White House with
a U.S senator and and they founded the
web accessibility initiative and that
gave some confidence to the US
government to update their section 508
rules the following year to clarify that
Electronic Services would be protected
by that legislation so it was really
obviously a legal requirement at that
point and to help web developers
actually do this and produce something
that actually worked the web content
accessibility guidelines were formed by
this group the following year that was
updated again a little while later and
then the version two of that actually
became part of EU law officially so the
EU law basically just says you need to
follow these guidelines version two it
was updated again a little bit later
now I think that as web developers the
main thing to observe is that we should
be grateful that these guidelines
existed so early and the fact that they
were written by people who understood
the web because if they were not then
today you would have to know about the
accessibility rules of like 100
different countries and try and comply
with all this stuff but thankfully
because these guidelines existed early
enough the countries that have
implemented legislation have largely
just said you know do what the
guidelines say so it's reasonably
sensible for us to know what to do
okay now let's get back to a little bit
more programming shall we because there
was a bit of a problem that Microsoft
had identified around then so they've
got this ASP programming thing we should
I showed you that you could do that from
front page you could do it from other
tools like visual interdev as well but
it had a bit of a problem the main
problem was it was not object oriented
and in 2000 everything had to be object
oriented that was the one true way that
all software must be written and the
other problem was there's this very
successful UI technology called Windows
forms that allows people to use a visual
designer to put their application
together and and put some logic into it
and you can't do anything like that on
the web you certainly can't do anything
like use JavaScript for interactive uis
at this time because that's just a
ridiculous toy language that nobody
could use in any sensible way so what is
Microsoft going to do well a guy you
might have heard of Scott Guthrie and
his manager Mark Anders they were set
the task of working on this and this is
apparently the original notebook that
they came up with a design in so let's
have a look at the design that they came
up with
okay so we're now in about 2002 and
you're a web developer and you are going
to make a website with this new
technology so you're going to be using
Windows XP probably and you've just
installed Microsoft Visual studio.net
it's just been released so we'll start
that up and we'll see that wow it's
really fast to start up firstly that's
quite impressive now obviously I'm
cheating slightly because I'm using
Hardware from 20 years in the future
which is also what we recommend for
modern visual studio if you yeah anyway
I'm going to create a new project
and I'm going to give it the very
delightful name of web application 11
because I'm not feeling too inventive
today and when that comes up you'll see
here's the visual designer that people
wanted just like in Windows forms and I
can start adding some UI to there like
I'm going to add a label I'm going to
just say hey there okay and I'm going to
add a button and let's move that along
and I'm going to do some really high
quality graphic design here where I'll
make that have an orange background
looks nice yeah okay now what is the
HTML that's coming out of there we can
switch over onto the HTML View and we
can see it's it's not too bad actually
it kind of looks alright with some
exceptions like what on Earth is that I
don't know what that is I don't want to
know it obviously shouldn't exist but
let's just run it anywhere and see what
comes up
all right so control F5 I'm in my
browser and we've got our button okay
now it won't do anything if I click it
let's add some interactive behaviors to
this and it was really nice okay we
could go and we can double click on that
button and we get into our code editor
and we can use the brand new c-sharp
programming language so I'm going to say
that when we click on this button I'm
going to change the text on it to say
you clicked at and then date time dot
now
okay run that again and then when I
click my button you'll see I get the
time to appear That's pretty nice and I
can click it again and each time I click
it the time is going to update so how is
this working how is it being interactive
even though we've got no JavaScript in
the page well one clue that we can get
is if we use the back and forwards
buttons so watch as I press back and I
forwards I'm going backwards and
forwards in time so what is going on
there that's a bit Advanced isn't it
like we can't even do that with modern
tech how are they doing that well the
trick is how it's implemented so if we
go into view Source here we can see this
giant blob of base64 encoded stuff it's
a bit hard to read I know
um can we change the I'll just leave it
Okay so we've got a massive base64 blob
and this represents the UI stamp so
there's an object-oriented
representation of the UI which is
serialized into that blob and when I
click a button it sends that to the
server it decodes it it builds the UI
state it runs the action that I've just
put some Logic for and re-renders the
new HTML and also re-emits that base64
plot so it can update again and as a
consequence each version of that ends up
in the browser's history that's a pretty
have a solution to doing interactivity
but it does some other quite nice
solutions to certain problems as well
for example
back at this time CSS was really weak
and if you wanted to do something like
horizontal and vertical centering of
something well you could probably just
forget unless you had like a PhD in
browser quirks or something like that
but if you were an asp net developer you
could do it quite well you could just go
like this
there we go that's probably about the
middle isn't it and then I just save
that go back into my browser reload and
there we go I can go home that's nice
now of course that worked just by
disgustingly like putting the absolute
pixel positions into the page there and
this whole idea started to fall apart a
few years later for reasons that we'll
talk about all right so this was the
hottest way of doing web development at
that time and it seemed like it would
always be like that until a couple of
years later something new came which
absolutely shook things up we have to
talk about Ruby on Rails so
uh David heinemeier Hansen DHA she's a
bit of a controversial figure these days
but back in 2004 he was just a humble
hipster programmer who decided that none
of the existing mainstream languages
were good enough for what he was doing
so he had to go out and find an
artisanal hand-crafted scripting
language from Japan that no one else had
heard about and he built a web
application with it called Basecamp and
he had a lot of really interesting new
ideas he made this into an open source
framework and when that landed people
were pretty amazed about what they saw
so let's have a quick look at what that
was like
I've got right here rails version 1.0
all right not the absolute first version
the oldest version that I can run and
I'm going to use that to generate a site
called my blog because everyone wants
blogs back in 2004 and that's going to
create the initial source code for me so
here's a new idea I wasn't using an IDE
I wasn't using a wizard I just created
stuff on the command line that was
pretty nice
um okay let's see if we can start this
up shall we so I'm going to go into the
scripts directory and I'm going to start
up now let's go
scripts server
all right so that's going to start up
the built-in web server there web brick
I'll open that in my browser and you'll
see we're now riding the rails it's
exciting and it gives us some tips like
start by defining your database config
so I'll go in here and I'll go and I
will set a database config and I'm going
to use sqlite3 now this is also yaml
which would have been new to web
developers at that time and have a look
at the architecture here can you see
that we've got models controllers views
well dhh didn't invent MVC but this was
pretty new to web developers at that
time it's applying this pattern in a
whole new way that was quite a big
surprise to people and to understand
what that does let's create a
a controller so I'm going to generate a
controller called blog with an action
called index on it and then I'll start
my server back up so I've now got this
controller here and if I want to
navigate to that I don't have to set up
any routing config I can just go to this
page and it shows up so there's another
new idea this convention over
configuration and file based routings
just built in nice and easy but if I
wanted to do something useful I'm going
to have to also generate a model so I'll
create a model for post for my blog
posts like that
okay and it's also generated some
automated tests for me which is pretty
clever uh web developers were not really
expected to do automated tests at that
time and then finally if I want to have
an actual UI for that I'm going to
scaffold a UI for the Post model
okay let's see if this works so if I go
in there and I go back now you'll see
it's trying to generate a UI but it
can't because there's no posts in our
table sorry no posts table in our
database so let's do yet another new
thing we'll generate a migration and
I'll call that posts and that is
defining encode how to update this the
state of our database schema so where is
that that is DB
in there but why is it not showing up it
is okay right so I'm going to put in a
bit of logic to create a table with a
title and a body and then when I uh run
that migration rake migrate it will
update the state of my database and then
finally I can run the server one more
time and we've actually got a working
blog application hi everyone
this is so
quick okay and then I'll hit that create
on that and it's done it so you can see
what an incredibly different programming
experience this was from asp.net at that
time there are so many new ideas going
on all at once this really shocked the
web development world and led to a whole
slew of CopyCat Frameworks that you
might have heard about later like Grails
and and asp.net MVC which came along a
few years after that so that's
server-side programming as it was at
that time what about client-side well I
think the JavaScript was kind of reborn
around 2005 to 2008 sort of time frame
and one of the things that triggered
that was this Web 2.0 wave and the
commercial pressures around that so Web
2.0 was when companies realized that
they could extract a lot of commercial
value from user generated content
and if you're a user which science will
you spend your time generating content
on well probably the ones that make it
fun for you and oh I better plug in my
laptop probably the ones that have a
nice user interface so there was a lot
of pressure on developers at that time
to create the best user interfaces they
could so that developers would actually
spend their time working on them
and some of the best work in this area
was done by Google the thing that I
remember from that time as a new
developer was absolutely shocking and
mind-blowing was Google Maps when this
first came out and you could just drag
the map and zoom in and out without even
having to reload the page it was just
mind-blowing everyone was astonished and
they wanted to create stuff like that
themselves but they didn't know how
everyone tried to invent their own
techniques but then this very
influential blog post came along uh by
Jesse James Garrett who'd said
um look at what Google's doing we can
extract some common patterns from this
and he even gave it a name Ajax which is
asynchronous Javascript and XML and he
tried to give some technical details
about how it works a lot of the stuff
that he wrote didn't really stand the
test of time like you know he talks
about engines and he talks about using
XML a lot which obviously we don't do
now but the core idea of doing requests
in the background and updating the page
dynamically that that really has stood
with us all this way and there was one
of the major enabling technology of the
time which I'm sure many of you have
used and probably still do use in
certain ways jQuery which allowed us to
simplify the horrible mess of very
inelegant Dom apis of the past and
compress it all down to a really elegant
way of describing what you were trying
to do that would also work consistently
across browsers and this was amazingly
successful fall at one point it went to
it was used by nearly 70 of the top
million sites and the amazing thing for
me is look at the peak of that graph
that only peaked like just over a year
ago it's like it's been going up the
whole time and it's only just started to
come back down
okay so at this time people were writing
a lot of JavaScript and if you write a
lot of JavaScript you need some way of
debugging it so what are the state of
browser Dev tools at that time well
let's have a look we'll go back into
this browser and we'll look for the dev
toolsman window
there isn't one okay so the closest that
you get to any browser Dev tools is
viewing the source in notepad which is
great
um and this guy
um Joe Hewitt he had been working at
Mozilla he's one of the founding
Engineers for Firefox but then he left
and he started building actual web
applications and he realized that it was
a massive pain because you couldn't
debug anything so he created a browser
plugin called Firebug and I can show it
to you here I've got Firefox and I've
installed the plugin so when I right
click on this I can inspect element and
you'll see a lot of stuff in there
that's familiar we've got a console HTML
view we can see the CSS we've got a
script debugger we've got a network
tracers and this design is largely stuck
with us all the way through and that was
Joe Hewitt in a community working
together on that it was even pretty much
just copied by Google as soon as they
released their Chrome browser so this is
Chrome version 1.0 let's see if I can
get to a real web page okay so Google
still works in Chrome 1.0 and if I right
click on this and inspect you can see
their early Dev tools right there it
doesn't have as much stuff in as fire as
Firebug but you know they were copying
some of the the core ideas so that was a
great thing that Joe Hewitt did for us
there
okay now what about uh design what about
responsive design well at this time
let's think about how mobile web users
actually consume the web well they had
very primitive web browsers and you had
to create these special mobile specific
sites that would work with these basic
web browsers but that all changed in
2008 for reasons that I'm sure you can
all guess uh this little thing came
along which changed the course of human
history in many ways but it certainly
changed things for web development and
this was jobs showing off the original
version of safari for the new iPhone and
he was very proud about the fact that it
wasn't using mobile sites it was using
the real desktop size so web developers
quickly realized two things one they
could not expect people to use these cut
down mobile sites anymore because people
will use your desktop site whether or
not you want them to and two that this
experience that jobs is showing I mean
it's all right but it's not that great
because all this zooming in and zooming
out it's pretty annoying it wouldn't be
better if the page was designed for this
little screen in the first place so this
gave rise to the idea of mobile first
design responsive design media queries
and that was standardized a couple of
years later in 2010.
okay so let's get back to JavaScript a
bit JavaScript was now winning on the
client and it was about time for it to
move to the server as well
Ryan Dahl was a an independent developer
he had been working on some Ruby on
Rails applications and he was very
influenced by these Web 2.0 uis he
wanted to be able to process lots of
stuff concurrently in the background and
he couldn't do it with rails because it
was not multi-threaded and he wanted to
do it with other scripting languages and
they weren't multi-threaded either and
he thought it would be impossible but
then he came up with the idea
just in the same way that JavaScript has
an event Loop in the browser it could
have an event loop on the server as well
and that could give him the concurrency
that he wanted and fortunately Google's
V8 engine had just been released as well
so he considered to be it to be obvious
that he should create a web server with
this he quit his job he spent six months
working on this and then he brought it
out in this conference in 2009.
okay so JavaScript is Everywhere by now
and this leads us to the next big step
in client-side JavaScript as well people
were really pushing past the limits of
what you could do with jQuery by now
they were building big applications and
they were becoming a mess and we needed
some discipline some way of structuring
things and a whole bunch of things came
out at the same time
uh people had really started to believe
in JavaScript because of this book
you've seen memes about it I'm not going
to repeat all that but you know people
were starting to respect this as a
language and people wanted to use it
this slide here this represents uh The
Inspirations and relationships between
different Spa Frameworks I didn't make
this slide I just stole it completely
from Sarah drasner she is a director of
engineering at Google and probably one
of the most authoritative people in the
world on this subject because not only
does she own the team that runs angular
she's also been on the or she still is
in fact on The View core team and she's
also a keynote speaker at react conf so
really knows how this stuff goes
together and I certainly can relate to
how these you know all these arrows it
makes sense to me and I want to talk
about this first wave because this is
what was going on in 2010 a whole bunch
of people had roughly the same idea at
the same time we've got this disciplined
way of writing programming from rails
and other patterns like model view
controller and things like that could we
do it in the browser
the first one to go public with this was
backbone that did a Hacker News Post on
October 13th of that year and then
exactly one week later knockout was
announced on Hacker News and another
thing happened on that very same day was
the first public release of angularjs
now angular had existed in Google for a
few years but this was the first time
again I had a public release on GitHub
none of these things were done in
coordination with each other it was just
an idea that was ready for the world it
had to come out and a whole bunch of
people did it at the same time
um so in honor of the fact that bakobon
was the first one I'm going to show you
how things looked inside backbone right
now so I've got a backbone sample
application right here we'll look at the
code in a sec but let's just start that
running so this is a to-do example I bet
some of you have seen this before I've
I've taken the code and simplified it a
bit there so I can add stuff to this
list I can mark them as done and so on
and the architecture of this application
is pretty familiar so we've got a model
here we've got a view and we've got a
sort of controller-ish kind of thing
it's always a bit ambiguous in an MVC
like what is the controller is it a view
model no one really cares the point is
that we've got model view separation
that's the key thing
and in this case we've got a model for
to-do's we've got a model for to-do
lists it's got the ability to calculate
Things based on what's in the model such
as how many tasks are remaining and to
render that in the UI we've it's using
underscore templating underscore is a
JavaScript library created by Jeremy
ashkenaz who also created backbone which
we're looking at right now he also went
on to create coffeescript which I'll
mention in a minute so he was very
influential and this underscore
templating system was rendering this
model into HTML and then wiring up
various things to it and then finally
we've got this controller and that is a
nice clean way of defining all the
different events that can occur and how
that's going to affect your model and
update the UI so that was pretty nice
and people adopted this sort of approach
very rapidly these Frameworks gain
traction very quickly and of course
they're still with us today or at least
newer versions of them are
okay so that brings us to a period of
very rapid complexity growth for web
developers people were writing a lot of
JavaScript by now and it went beyond the
point where even just a nice framework
could help them people by now needed a
new language to try and allow them to do
this at a higher scale
typescript is the one that's ultimately
one the idea of compiling stuff to
JavaScript wasn't new with typescript so
I just mentioned ashkenas and his
coffeescript language that was probably
the first one that really got a lot of
attention and typescript followed on by
that by adding the a full proper type
system obviously you will know about
this because typescript is now I think
maybe the second most popular
programming language in the world it's
been an unbelievable success story
they're really really effective way of
solving real problems for developers and
going with the fact that this is
compiled and people are doing so much of
this we now need compilation and
bundling systems so webpack came along
to fill that need and I've even thrown
in kubernetes here now I know that's not
really specific to front-end web
development but it just gives you a hint
of how much stuff web developers were
being expected to know about by now it's
not just front-end Dev and back end and
styling and build systems and stuff it's
also now Cloud orchestration it's
becoming a very very sophisticated era
and it's starting to get to the point
where people are going to need to push
back against this a little bit but one
other thing came out around this time
which has been pretty important and that
is webassembly so this is the thing that
finally separates us from that design
directive that Andreessen gave in the
beginning saying you have to be able to
just type the script in
so the idea at this point is there are
lots of other great programming
languages out there we want to run them
in a browser too so this app wasn't just
Mozilla I know people often say it was
Mozilla that did this but it was a
collaboration that started in 2015
between Mozilla Google Microsoft and the
the webkit team working on some of the
safari stuff and they came up with this
design and I've put it down for 2017
because that's when it actually shipped
in all your browsers
so would anyone like to know what my
absolute favorite thing you can do with
webassembly is well I will show you it's
running.net in a browser so just purely
as an illustration of webassembly and
for no other reason I'm going to show
you the original Blazer prototype here
so this was created for an NDC
conference demo actually and if you've
done any Blazer programming you probably
might recognize this project template
because bizarrely we've never changed it
over the years but the thing that's
really worth looking at here is what
this is doing inside the browser so I
need to be on the home page to load that
okay so this is if we look in this
network Trace yes it's getting.net dlls
and it's running them but it's doing it
using webassembly and before we had the
modern.net for webassembly runtime this
prototype was created with something
called.net anywhere which is a net
runtime made by one person called Chris
bacon and that compiled to web family
very easily and the cool thing about it
is look how small it is 52 kilobytes of
the.net runtimes were probably going to
be tens or hundreds of megabytes but
webassembly allowed us to get this into
browsers in just 50 kilowatts which is
pretty extraordinary it didn't have that
much functionality you know there's a
lot of.net stuff it couldn't run which
is partly why it was so small but it was
enabled by this new technology that came
out in 2017. okay so that almost brings
us to the current day and I'm not going
to try and interpret what's happened for
the last couple of years because I think
like the dust hasn't really settled on
History yet we don't know what's going
to be important in the long run but we
we can start to think a little bit about
where we might be heading in the future
what are some of the big trends that we
see going on one of them I think is a
bit of a pushback against the
sophistication and the number of things
that web developers are expected to know
maybe we're hitting some kind of
limiting point
some of the technologies that are
emerging might start to help us reduce
that a little bit so one of them is at
the moment we have to do so much stuff
to prepare our content for browsers
wouldn't it be simpler if the browsers
could just work with the stuff that we
gave them without us having to build it
all HTTP 2 and 3 for example mean that
you don't really have to bundle content
anymore it's just as efficient to serve
lots of small files as it is to serve
one big file and then the type Erasure
proposal would be a way of running
languages like typescript directly
inside a browser without having to
compile them simply by teaching the
browser to ignore the type annotations
and other things that the browser
doesn't understand and then this CSS
nesting which is not just a proposal
that is happening I think this allows us
to get much of the benefits that you
have with things like less and SAS just
by baking more and more of those
features inside the browser one of the
big features of lesson SAS is just the
ability to nest selectors and so if we
can simply make that a native feature of
the browser then in a lot of cases we
might not need any other thing
okay now another big Trend that started
to emerge in the last year or two is the
rise of the meta Frameworks I don't know
if you're familiar with that but the
basical idea now is especially in
JavaScript world people are using so
many Frameworks that they kind of need a
framework to manage their Frameworks and
that's what a meta framework is I'm
going to show you one of those in a
minute but it's various things like
svelte and Astro and so on and they are
bringing some really new interesting
ideas the core thing is that by having a
single framework that knows about server
side client-side build system and IDE
you can put that all together and then
you can build new kinds of features that
span all of those things which wouldn't
be possible if you just had Frameworks
in their own little silos
so we'll check that in a minute and then
finally there's a little bit of a
movement I would say towards delivering
your web applications not just on a
couple of servers in certain places in
the world but in thousands or tens of
thousands of locations all around the
world I hear a lot of web developers now
getting very interested in trying to
ship their stuff all over so that you
get these like single digit millisecond
response times for your users and you
pretty much can never be down because
like it would take you know you'd have
to bring down the entire Global
infrastructure to take down your website
at that point
so let's have a look at these meta
Frameworks okay I'm going to show you an
example of svelt Kit just because it's
got a bunch of interesting new ideas
that I think are worth looking at so
over here I've got a new sveltec
application that I've created from its
template and if I go in my browser then
we'll see okay it's just like a static
message not much to see there if we look
in the source code it doesn't have much
either but it does allow us to use
svelte the client-side spa framework to
build an interactive UI we can see the
initial source code is just some static
content and if I start editing that
let's uh let's see how the hot reload
stuff works so I can just start typing
hey NDC and I'm not pressing save right
now I did not press save I just stopped
typing and you see it updated in the
browser because it knows about my IDE
and I could even do things like put some
style in and again I did not save I just
put some code in and it knows how to
bundle all the different types of
content that I provide and get it into
the browser and I as a developer don't
need to think about how that stuff works
so that's nice all right now let's add a
little bit of functionality here and
everyone loves counters down there so
I'm going to create a counter okay and
then I'm going to create a page in there
and I'm going to give it the rather
strange but important name of plus page
dot svelte which follows the framework's
naming convention and I'll just put some
content in there and if I want to get to
that page I don't have to configure my
routing system I'm just going to go to
counter so taking a bit of inspiration
from rails there we've got this
convention-based routing system and I
could put in the actual Logic for a
counter now you can see it supports
typescript as well I don't have to
configure how that works it just you
know knows how to build this stuff for
me we've got account we'll display the
count we've got a button when you click
it it increments the count pretty basic
stuff so when I go back over here it
increments the count okay cool nothing
special yet now let me show you a bit of
the meta framework coming through
so I'm going to go back to this home
page here I'm going to add a link to my
counter just a normal HTML link then go
back to the home page and you can see
the link is there I can click it it
works nothing surprising but the cool
thing is what happens on the network
when I do that
so when I'm here right now it has not
loaded any of the code for the counter
at all it's just loaded the code need
for the home page and when I go to the
counter you can see it fills in just the
little bit of extra code that's needed
for that other page so it's
incrementally delivering the different
parts of my application as I navigate
around that's called code splitting so
that's pretty good but what about doing
some slightly more sophisticated stuff
still let's say that I want to have some
server-side State at the moment everyone
who comes here gets a different counter
what if I want them to share a counter
well I'm going to start by factoring out
what might seem to be something like a
code behind file so I'm going to have a
page called page.ts here where I can put
some type script in and this you know
code behind it feels a little bit like
asp.net web forms coming back again
there and the logic that I'll put in
here is we'll have an initial count
value of one two three just so we can
see it's different and we use this
special load method to say this is the
data that we want to transfer into our
page and then to actually use it in the
page I'm going to go back to here and
I'm going to put in the actual Imports
here that will load that data from my
code behind that so now I come back you
can see that the count is one two three
which is this initial value I'm saying
and I can still increment it but it's
still all working completely client-side
here and so if I reload obviously I'm
going to lose the state and it's all
evaluating this stuff in the browser if
I want to run some stuff on the server I
can simply go to this file and rename it
to
page.server.ts and just by doing that it
is now going to run that bit of the
logic server side and deal with
serializing that state into my
client-side page whenever I go there so
that's pretty good but when I make
changes to this counter you'll see there
still only changes in the browser's
memory it's not changing the server side
count if I want to do that I'm going to
need to add some sort of Json endpoint
that I can call from the client and I
can do that by adding an action pretty
simple stuff it's just a method with a
name and it's going to increment the
count and then to actually hit this
action instead of having a button I'm
going to have a traditional HTML form
doesn't even use JavaScript in this case
just to post to that end point on the
server so now when I reload you see when
I click this it's updating the count and
when I reload it does not lose it and in
fact this whole thing now is purely
server-side application it's all server
rendered every time I click this it's
pushing
um it's reloading the page completely
from the server so in effect we've kind
of just reinvented asp.net web forms
right now with server side rendering
that's pretty good it can work without
script but you know this browser does in
fact support JavaScript so could we
perhaps even have some kind of hybrid
where it would support server-side
execution or client-side execution and
dynamically use both depending on what's
best well we can so I can go to this
form here and I can add this magic
little use enhance thing on it which
needs to import a certain thing
why can't I quick fix that okay I can
now good and now that has been enhanced
when I'm back in my browser when I click
this you'll see it's not reloading the
page anymore it's now still updating the
state on the server through an HTTP post
but it's getting the result back and
doing client-side rendering because this
browser supports it but if I was a
crawler it would be doing server side
rendering so that is pretty nice way of
getting the benefits of birth so the
point I'm I'm making here is that by
having uh this meta framework we can
have new types of features now I know if
you're a net developer you might think
hang on I think I've already got a meta
framework because like I've already got
this one thing that does server and
client and IDE and build and stuff and
that's kind of true but the fact that
these ideas are coming into JavaScript
now is inspiring a lot of new innovation
in terms of those features which the
whole web Community can benefit from so
I think that's pretty exciting stuff so
there we go that's all we've got time to
talk about this morning
um I think we can agree that the web has
come a long way since burners Lee's
Information Management proposal I don't
know if he really knew what he was
unleashing on the world when he did that
um but the overall thing that I think we
should take away from this
um is that we can change the course of
the web like the the people who make
these decisions in some cases they're
big corporations but a lot of the
decisions along the way were made by
individual Engineers so think about
people like Nicola pillow Who basically
rescued the web from Oblivion right at
the beginning by coming up with this way
of rendering web content as text think
about Joe Hewitt who decided that it
wasn't good enough to just view Source
in notepad he came up with a way of
having modern browser Dev tooling think
about Ryan Dahl who saw the connections
between multi-threading and JavaScript
and the VA engine and created a new way
of doing server side program with
JavaScript these were just individual
engineers and so you uh are those
Engineers you're here at this conference
you can chat to each other and come up
with some of these ideas about where
we're going to go next and I'm very
excited to see it and hopefully be part
of what you create so uh have a really
good rest of the day I hope you have a
wonderful rest of conference and um I'll
see you all around
[Applause]
the street cool yeah